Новий очільник митної служби України
Максим Нефьодов
запропонував скласти єдину базу вартості розмитнення автомобілів
на основі даних про уже ввезені машини.
Наразі українські митники використовують
німецькі каталоги "Шваке" для вираховування мита.
На кордоні є якісь так звані утаємничені
каталоги "Шваке", за якими визначається ціна,
за якими комусь не пропускають, комусь нараховують в три рази і так далі.
Тож давайте розберемося, що таке німецькі каталоги "Шваке"
і як німці розмитнюють машини.
Це сайт за адресою Шваке Де Е, який є агрегатором,
що збирає інформацію з усіх сайтів купівлі-продажу автомобілів у Німеччині.
Це абсолютно відкрита платформа,
де будь-хто за оплату у 7 євро 90 центів
може отримати інформацію про ринкову вартість свого автомобіля.
Для цього треба внести дані про своє авто -
такі, як модель, рік випуску, пробіг, комплектація, пошкодження.
От на прикладі цього БМВ 2017 року випуску
"Шваке" видає два основні параметри ціни:
за скільки таку автівку у вас придбає перекупник
та скільки вона вам коштуватиме у перекупника.
Відповідно - 29 тисяч 400 євро і 33 850 євро.
Цим сайтом німці користуються, визначаючи
реальну ринкову ціну своєї вже вживаної автівки
для купівлі-продажу в самій Німеччині.
Що ж стосується розмитнення машин, ввезених з-за меж ЄС,
то для нарахування мита німецькі митники послуговуються як своєю власною базою даних,
так і каталогом "Шваке". Безмитне імпортне ввезення автомобіля у ФРН
дозволено лише у випадку переїзду особи на проживання до Німечччини -
за умови що автівка зареєстрована на приватну особу
і була у її користуванні не менше шести місяців.
Якщо німець, наприклад, вирішив особисто привезти нову автівку зі США,
йому треба буде сплатити мито у розмірі приблизно 10% від вартості авто.
Також треба сплатити податок на оборот імпорту і вартість транспортування.
Разом всі сплати становитимуть десь до третини вартості автомобіля.
З 1993 року митні кордони в межах ЄС відсутні.
Якщо німець вирішив самостійно завезти нову автівку з іншої країни ЄС, наприклад Франції,
він сплатить податок на додану вартість по прибутті до ФРН.
З точки зору німецького податкового законодавства, нові транспортні засоби -
це ті автомобілі, які мають пробіг менше 6 тисяч кілометрів
або початкова експлуатація яких на момент придбання становила не більше півроку.
Привезення німцем вживаної автівки з іншої країни ЄС
може бути вигідним через відмінності в оподаткуванні в різних країнах.
ПДВ та інші податки вже включені в ціну автівки у країні придбання
і додаткових мит або податків платити не доведеться.